Okay. Bitte schön. Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Theser Gürtas. Ich bin die zuständige
Arschdehnprüfe, bevor wir zu ihrem Bescheiden kommen, lassen Sie mich kurz Ihre personische
Daten notieren. Wie heißen Sie das? Ja, mein Name ist Paul Maier. Paul Maier. Könnten Sie Ihr
nach dem Nachname langsamer gestehen? Ja, mein Vornamer ist Paul, Paula, Anton, Ulrich Ludwig.
Mein Nachname ist Maier. Martha, Emyl, Y, Emyl Richard. Und Frau Maier, ja? Nee, Herr Maier. Paul.
Paul Maier. Ja, Herr Maier. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin fünfjahr alt.
Am vierten, 15, 1977. Vierter, May, 1977. Vierter, Fünfter, 77. Wie groß und wie ich
wie sind Sie? Ich bin 171 groß und bin 86 Kilogramm. Okay. Wo wohnen Sie, Paul Maier? Wo ich wohne?
Ich wohne in Frankfurt. Wie heißt Ihr Haus als oder Ihre Hausärztin? Meine Hausarzt ist Dr. Axus.
Axus, ja. Okay. Was sind Sie von werbuff? Ich bin Mala. Mala, okay. Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet. Okay, haben Sie Kinder? Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
zwei Kinder. Okay. Maier, was kann ich für Sie tun? Und so erfolgreich. Ich habe seit zwei Wochen Schmerzen
in der Beihre meiner linken Schulter-Region. Es zieht mir so in den linken Arm rein und
ich fühle es bis in meinen Finger. Fühlen Sie? Ich spüre die Schmerzen von meinem Schulterbereich bis in meinem
Finger. Okay, okay. Also ich habe so irgendwo im Bereich der Schulterschmerzen. Okay, okay.
Sind Sie nicht langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten? Sie sind damals über die Nacht aufgetreten.
Ja, über die Nacht. Ich würde sagen plötzlich. Ich bin morgens aufgestanden und habe Schmerzen gehabt.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall? Einen Unfall? Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Okay, okay. Und wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzfäler?
Eins von eins bis zehn, wobei ein sehr leichter Schmerz in sich. Ich würde sagen fünf.
Okay, und ich trage die Schmerzen in Ihre linken Arm aus. Genau. Und auf Finger.
Bis in die Finger, ja. Okay, haben Sie Traubheitsgefühl in linken Arm?
Hab ich nicht. Oder Krippeln? Krippeln habe ich auch nicht. Und leiden Sie an, musst du schwächer oder musst du Kraftlosigkeit?
Kraftlosigkeit habe ich nicht. Okay. Ja, okay. Haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie Ihre Körperthermatur gemessen?
Gemessen habe ich nicht, aber ich denke nicht, dass ich ein Fieber habe. Ich fühle mich, ist bezieglich gut.
Okay, okay. Bei Lepe Traubheitsgefühl, Kraftlosigkeit. Okay. Und gibt es sonstige Bescheiden?
Ich weiß nicht, das linke Schulter-Schmerz macht mich ein bisschen unrichtig.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich habe. Sonst habe ich das hinzubekommen. Es ist ein ständiger Schmerz, Schulter-Nackenbereich, der ein bisschen an der linken Finger ausstrahlt.
Und der Schmerz ist fast immer da. Ja, okay. Dauerhaft da. Mal weniger, mal mehr, mal weniger, aber dauerhaft da.
Okay. Gibt es irgendetwas, was die Schmerzen, wie in der oder versteigt?
Wenn ich meine Arbeit aufnehme, meine Malartichtigkeitswache, habe ich ja mehr Schmerzen.
Wenn ich nicht viel arbeite, habe ich weniger Schmerzen. Also habe ich Schmerzen, aber es ist weniger.
Okay, Belastung abhängig kann man ausdagen.
Für real hatten Sie schon ein Mal, diese beiden? Nein, hatte ich nicht gehabt.
Erst einmal? Ja.
Sind Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt gewesen? Nein.
Okay, okay, Herr Maja. Okay.
Gibt es im Kranken-Vorgeschichte wichtige Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ich meine, Bluthochdruck, leiden Sie an Bluthochdruck, drücke Krankheit oder hohe Blutzeitweite?
Ja, also ich nehme Medikamente wegen Kollisterien ein.
Ja, okay.
Und nehme auch Medikamente für Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck, okay. Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit drei Jahren.
Und Kollisterienmärkte? Seit wann?
Ja, der hat damals vor drei Jahren aufgemessen, damals waren die hoch, aber ich weiß nicht, seit wann die haben.
Seit mindestens drei Jahren ist es bekannt, ja.
Okay.
Sonst die Krankheiten? Sonst die Krankheiten?
Zugekrankheit oder andere? Nein.
Okay. Und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden, ja damals an Blindern, wo ich jung war, war zehn Jahre alt.
Okay, ansonsten, oder sonstige Operationsfirmen gibt es?
Ne.
Okay. Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja.
Und gegen andere Krankheiten?
Geimpft? Ja, ich hatte alle Impfungen, die seit der Geburt gehabt.
Okay.
Und gibt es wichtige Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie?
Ich meine vielleicht Bluthochdruck, Superkrankheit oder Bluthochvertreter?
Was meinen Sie mit Familie?
Ja, Mutter, Vater, Schwester oder Kinder.
Also mein Schwager und so weiter ist auch meine Familie.
Ja, natürlich. Sie sind auch in der Familie, aber diese Familien-Teilwand-Kate haben Sie auch genetische Teilwand-Tröder.
Deswegen ist es lustig.
Die meinen vielleicht verwandten ersten Grades?
Ja, genau.
Also meine Mutter, sie leidet an Zuckerkrankheit, nimmt da Medikamente ein.
Okay, weiß ich, wissen Sie?
Nee, die hat es später bekommen, irgendwie ab 40.000 Lebensjahr zu mir gesagt, irgendwann später bekommen.
Okay, okay.
Bei ihr wurde mal die Schildrüse operiert.
Ihre Mutter?
Ja, bei meiner Mutter hatte irgendwie eine Schildrüse in Erkrankung.
Ich weiß nicht, was es war, wurde operiert, auch schon länger her.
Und mein Vater, der hat Herz-Rhythmostörung, aber ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Dann nimmt auch irgendwelche Medikamente ein und geht es alle Jahr zu, er arzt.
Okay.
Ja, verstanden.
Und die Schwester oder Kinder?
Weil ich habe einen Bruder, der ist gesund.
Der ist auch jünger als ich.
Und meine Kinder, die sind auch gesund.
Ja, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein, habe ich keine Probleme damit.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit verändert?
Mein Appetit, nee.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuttgang oder beim Wasserlasten?
Nee, habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Okay, sehr gut.
Haben Sie Chitres auf der Arbeit oder gibt es irgendwelche Probleme,
die Sie belastet?
Stuttgastbelastet?
Nee.
Als etwas mich belastet ist, meine Schmerzen in meiner Schulterregion.
Ja, genau.
Seit zwei Wochen, ja.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, gegen Bruder-Tropf-Drück und Cholesterin,
vorher Cholesterin, ein paar Medikamente einnehmen.
Weißt du, Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, also wegen Blutdruck-Drück nehme ich Ramipril, 10 Milligramm ein.
Morgens eine und abends nehme ich eine Sympastatin, 40 Milligramm.
Ramipril nehmen Sie am Morgen.
Morgens 10 Milligramm.
Und Sympastatin nehme ich abends eine Tablette ein.
Okay, wie viele Milligramm?
40.
Okay.
Okay, gibt es andere Medikamente?
Nee, kein anderer Medikamente.
Beiber Arsch nehmen Sie etwas Beiber Arsch oder?
Ja, das halt zu Hause ist manchmal, ne?
Parasitamol oder im Profen oder so.
Aber jetzt aktuell habe ich nichts eingenommen.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie Heimaja?
Ja.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit 15 Jahren.
15 Jahren.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie am Prozakt?
Ich habe eine halbe Packung.
Am Tag brauche ich schon, ja.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Trink schon, wenn es so feierabend ist.
Dann trinke ich gerne schon mal so 1, 2 Flaschen Bier.
1, 2 Flaschen Bier.
Aber das ist ja kein Alkohol, das ist flüssiges Brot.
Ja, kann man auch, man kann auch sagen.
Und nur feieralte oder feieralte, wenn sie...
Hey, nicht feieralte, sondern wenn es feierabend ist.
Feierabend, feieralte.
Ja, jeden Tag, jeden Tag.
Passieren.
Passieren, ja, kann man schon sagen, ja?
Ja, jeden Abend.
Ein schönes, kaltes Bier schmeckt gut, ne?
Schönes vom Kühlschrank, bei dem Wetter.
Ja, sehr heiß ist ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie sonst die Drogen?
Drogen?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie Drogen geschrieben wird.
Ja, das ist eine bittine Frage, nehmen Sie nicht bei so einem, ich stelle es für dich.
Aber ich muss auch stellen.
Okay.
Ja, okay, keine Kontakt, ja?
Okay, sind Ihnen eine pünzliche Allergien bekannt?
Allergien bekannt? Ja.
Damals, wo ich operiert wurde, hat man mir Penicillin gegeben.
Wo ich als Kind als Glindermilk...
Ja, genau.
Als Glindermilk, als eine Glindermilkoperation nach Tuftier,
hat man mir Penicillin gegeben,
und da hätte ich, sagt man, mir schlecht geatmet, allergisch reagiert.
Seitdem darf ich keinen Penicillin mehr einnehmen.
Okay, ich verstanden.
Gibt es andere?
Andere, wenn nicht, nicht, dass ich mich bekannt.
Okay, leiden Sie an Unfallcheck-Infigkeiten?
Ich hatte mal vor Jahren wegen irgendwelchen Schmerzen im Knie,
hatte ich mal Dickler-Fernack eingenommen,
da habe ich Magenunverträglichkeit gehabt,
Magenkrämpfe bekommen.
Das kam jetzt raus.
Okay, Herr Meija, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie dazu hinzugezüge, oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, man liest ja viel im Internet.
Wenn ich so höre, ich habe Schmerzen im Bereich
der linken Schulter.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe Angst, ob man irgendwas mit dem Herzen ist,
ist. Weiß nicht, wie, an was denken Sie denn?
Ja, Sie haben recht, wenn man Internet etwas im Internet recherchiert, kann man viele Informationen
bekommen. Ja, aber das ist sehr früh etwas genau zu sagen. Deswegen zuerst würde ich gerne
einfach untersuchen und durchstören. Dann kann ich etwas sagen.
Wie geht es weiter?
Ja, nehmen Sie, ich würde gerne zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen,
ich würde gerne Sie abteilung schicken.
Ja, ich möchte ja, wie ist die Knochen?
Wie ist die Knochen?
Wie sind die Knochenstrukturen?
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht, das kann sein.
Wir sprechen nochmal.
Danke.
Tschüss.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie arbeiten, dann linke Schmerzenanfangen.
Insbesondere wenn ich über Kopf arbeiten mache, wenn ich streiche an der Decke oben
oder mein Arm die ganze Zeit bewege, streich arbeiten mache oder etwas hochhebe,
dann habe ich Schmerzen in meinem Schulternackenbereich, Schulterbereich.
Mit Ausstrahlung in den linken Arm.
Mit dem Atmen? Nein.
Ich werde nur arbeiten aufgetreten, aber Sie sind da, seit den zwei Wochen,
an dem Tag, wo ich aufgestanden bin, aber die sind durch die Arbeit, durch Belastung,
durch Tragen oder durch Überkopfarbeiten, das sind die Schmerzen mehr.
Ich habe auch Probleme, so Schulternackenbereich auch.
Schmerzen zusammen, haben Sie Kalten Schweissigkeit oder Herr Stolpern?
Nein, ich bin nicht irgendwie aufgefallen.
Danke schön.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Übelkeit habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schwindel?
Schwindel ist mir nicht, nein, Schwindelig.
Ich bin schocker in Schlegigkeit.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Nach so einem langen Tag ein bisschen, aber üblich, nicht irgendwie anders als vorher.
Das ist ja immer so, wenn man die Schuhe anzieht, abends sind die ein bisschen enger,
wenn die Monus anziehen sind.
Aber nicht irgendwie auffällig geschwollene Beine habe ich nicht.
Ein ganz kurzer Moment, bitte.
Ich bin wieder da.
Hallo, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, bitte.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie im Armen überwärmte Arme oder Blässe, Haarausfall
oder Haarveränderung?
Veränderung. Also die Farbe ist gleich, die Temperatur oder Verfärbung, Haar und so weiter sind identisch gleich.
Wenn Sie andere Arme vergleichen, gibt es eine Veränderung?
Nein, nur dass ich Schmerzen habe. Es zieht so in den linken Armen.
Ich muss mal einen Akku gerade laden.
Ich hatte ein schwaches Akku gehabt, aber jetzt geht es wieder weiter.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, einen auslöser davor?
Beim Ausdrucks dafür könnte ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Haben Sie sich verletzt?
Letzt auch nicht. Also ich bin nicht gestürzt.
Meine Frau hat mich auch nicht geschlagen.
Also ich wusste nicht, ich habe halt vielleicht falsch geschlafen, weiß ich nicht.
Also ich bin morgens aufgestanden.
Ich hatte Schmerzen, die waren nicht sehr stark.
Aber wenn ich es belaste, wird ich stärker.
Haben Sie sich bemerkt, eine Bewegung oder eine Geschränkung?
Wenn ich zum Beispiel meinen Nacken hin und her drehe,
kann ich schlecht nach links gucken.
Ansonsten kann ich aber nach oben bewegen.
Da habe ich keine großartige, nur Schmerzen.
Eine Bewegung zur Einschränkung ist nur, wenn ich meinen Kopf nach links drehen möchte.
Da habe ich so, zieht es ein bisschen mehr.
Haben Sie Nackensteifigkeit auch?
Ja, also ich kann meinen Nacken schon bewegen, aber ich kann halt nicht ganz nach links schauen.
Weißt du nicht, was du mit Nackensteifigkeit meinen?
Meine Verspannung an den Nacken.
Ja, irgendwie zieht es da halt.
Nacken, Schulter, Arm, überall in dieser Region.
Haben Sie gegen Schmerzen einen Mitgewandt eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Wenn Sie mir etwas empfehlen, würde ich etwas einnehmen.
Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was ich einnehme. Ich weiß ja nicht, was ich habe.
Wie kühlen Sie sich besonders morgen?
Morgen.
Morgen ist es stärker, wenn ich möchte oder nicht?
Morgen, nein, normal.
Ich mache zwar ein, zwei Mal auf in der Nacht wegen den Schmerzen,
aber ich kann schlafen und morgens stehe ich auf und habe halt die Schmerzen.
Und wenn ich arbeite, sind die Schmerzen mehr.
Ich würde teile anfangen.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, guten Abend.
Ich würde gerne einen neuen Patienten berichten.
Passt es Ihnen gerade?
Ja, bitte schön.
Danke schön.
Paul Maya ist ein 50-Jähriger Patient,
der sich wegen Schulterschmerzen bei uns vorgestellt hat.
Seine Schmerzen sind plötzlich vor zwei Wochen aufgetreten.
Die leiden an keine Traumheit gefühlt, Kraftlosigkeit.
Aber er hat Ausgetreten, Ausgetragung.
Er hat eine Schmerzbeugung.
Er ist eine Frau.
Und er leidet an, hat redet die Pärfonie seit drei Jahren und fohe Polis der Linke,
gleich auch drei Jahre.
Und vor Erkrankungen sind Appendekidemie mit 10 Jahre alt oder lebensjahr, 10 Jahre lebensjahr bekannt.
Im Ski-Tatus ist Aktial. In der Familienanämnese finden sich seine Mutter an Superkrankheit und ja, Superkrankheit,
an Superkrankheit leidet und seine Vater und seine Mutter leidet an Zuckerkrankheit.
Ja, genau, man kann Aussagen, ja leider.
An der französischen Bekrankheit und seine Vater an den Praxisstrichen,
seine Bruder und seine Kinder sind gesund.
Und vegetative Anämnese war unaufregig und er nimmt regelmäßig für den Mitglied 10 mg morgens
und im Maske 10, 50 mg abends ein und bei Bedarf, Parasitomol oder Ibuprofen nimmt er jeden Schmerzen ein.
Und er ist trauherrsch seit ungefähr 50 Jahren, 15 Jahren, hat er halber Zeit geraucht.
Seit wieviel Jahren?
15, habe ich.
15, ja.
Da hat er 50 verstanden.
Nein, 15, das entspricht 7,5 Jahre.
Und Alkoholkonsum, er trinkt jeden Abend 2 oder 3 Flaschen Diab zu Roggenbüderperne ein.
Er hat Penzin und Diplopenac, ja, Penzin Allergie und auch als Unverzweglichkeit ist Diplopenac Unverzweglichkeit bekannt.
Ja, ja, seine Penzin Allergie oiseizlich ist Nürn oder Luftmord.
Aber Diplopenac, wenn er Diplopenac nimmt, hat er Mademflerk.
An jenehse und genügend Toten am Ehesten, Dispuls Prolapsus im Heißbereich.
Okay.
Als Zeitagsdiagnose Frachtur, Oberchenkel Frachtur oder...
Oberchenkel?
Keine.
Nein, Oberchenkel.
Meine Ospelische Verzweifelung.
Oberchenkel Frachtur oder...
Frachtur, aber der ist ja gestürzt.
Nein, keine.
Ich habe keine Hütte an Diagnose.
Wie kommen Sie an einem Frachtur als Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, vielleicht.
Er hat Osteoporose.
Einfach so in der Nacht.
In der Nacht?
Ja, in der Nacht.
Die Beziehung gibt es einen Wort.
Viel ist viel und wenig ist wenig.
Natürlich kann man einen Tumor haben.
Dieser Tumor kann zu einem Oberfrachtur kommen.
Aber das ist alles selten.
Als Differenzialdiagnose, was würden Sie noch denken?
Könnte zum Beispiel eine...
Metastase?
Nicht anstelle mit einer Krankung.
Was ist meistens bei Leuten, die viel Armbewegen malen?
Im Schultergelenk kann man bestimmte Sachen haben.
Zum Beispiel eine Arthrose.
Selten bei einem 45-jährigen Mann, aber kann man haben.
Das ist mehr als ein Beruf, weil kein Trauma da ist.
Eine Omarthrose zum Beispiel.
Oder eine AC-gelängstarthrose kann man haben.
Oder man kann Rotatom-Manschetten-Lessionen haben.
Rotatom-Manschetten, zum Beispiel Socraspinatus, Sehnen,
Tendinopathy, Sehnenruptur, Tendinitis, Kralkarya.
Zum Beispiel.
Das ist eher wahrscheinlich als wir adden.
Okay, danke schön.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich gerne
ein paar diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Wie?
Moment, wenn Sie sagen, wenn sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
wie würden Sie das bestätigen?
Was würde ich gerne?
Diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Nee, aber das ist danach.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn sich die Diagnose bestätigt,
was müssen Sie machen, um erst die Diagnose zu bestätigen,
damit Sie Röntgen oder irgendwelche diagnostische Massnahmen machen,
haben Sie verstanden oder war es zu schnell?
Eigentlich drin kann ich dann sagen, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn sich die Diagnose bestätigen,
wenn sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt,
wenn Sie das sagen, dann haben Sie etwas gemacht.
Ja, ich habe keine Stattung.
Was haben Sie gemacht, damit sich das bestätigt,
damit Sie eine Diagnostik machen?
Ja, ich habe keine Stattung.
Wie kann man sagen?
Eigentlich wissen Sie, das war richtig,
das ist nicht falsch, das ist richtig,
das waren die Änderungen, die Sie gesagt haben.
Ich will nur wissen, wie Sie da zu kommen.
Okay, sollte ich die Diagnose bestätigen,
würde ich gerne...
Wie bestätigt Sie das?
Ja, ich sage es noch nicht, würde ich gerne
einfach diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Ja.
Stopp. Da ist dieser Fehler drin.
Diagnostische Maßnahmen sind z.B. MRT, Röntgen und Reih-Schall Diagnostik.
Aber wie kann man diese Diagnostik oder die Verdachtsdiagnose erhärten, indem man eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung macht?
Zunächst macht man erst mal eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Und wenn sich meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigt, dann würde ich sagen, ich habe ihn körperlich untersucht.
Ich denke doch, dass Herr Banschein Vorfall hat.
Jetzt habe ich das bestätigt, also meine Verdachtsdauer erhärtet.
Jetzt will ich noch ein paar Maßnahmen machen.
Ich habe eine Diagnostik mit irgendwelchen Apparaten eine Diagnostik machen.
Verstanden? Ja.
Weil wenn Sie sagen, wenn es bestätigt, wie bestätigt, also mit Diagnostik kann ich bestätigen.
Aber bevor ich eine Diagnostik mache, haben Sie eigentlich richtig gedacht,
muss man erst mal eine körperliche Untersuchung machen.
Wenn ich durch die körperliche Untersuchung meine, wenn er zum Beispiel nur eine Rotationsschmerz am Arm hat durch die körperliche Untersuchung,
dann würde ich nicht an Banschein Vorfall denken.
Dann hat sich das nicht erhärtet.
Dann denke ich eher an Arthrose oder Super Spinatus-Syndrom.
Aber durch die körperliche Untersuchung erhärte ich meine Verdachtsdiagnose.
Ah, ja, das kann sein.
Der hat keine Rotationsschmerz.
Aber dann würde ich denken, vielleicht hat es Banschafe.
Also würde ich dann Diagnostik machen.
Die Logik.
Okay.
Gott, Entschuldigung.
Kein Problem.
Ich muss meine Sette ändern.
So weiteren Abkleben würde ich gerne körperliche Untersuchung,
Blutabnahme und röntgenarm Schulter.
Ja, Schulter.
Wenn Sie Verdachtsdiagnose haben, Banschein Vorfall,
das würde man eher...
MRT.
MRT auch.
Nee, ja, das MRT, richtig.
Aber wenn Sie sagen Schulter röntgen.
Ich habe Verdacht, Banschein Vorfall ist hier,
direkt in die Schulter.
Ja, ich möchte etwas ausschließen.
Wo?
Weil wenn Sie sagen, ich habe Verdachtdiagnose Banschein Vorfall,
wo ist die Banscheibe?
An der Halsfirma-Solle.
Also dann würde ich sagen, wenn ich etwas röntgen würde,
würde ich etwas ausschließen, dass keine Degeneration in der Halsfirma-Solle ist.
Also würde ich die Halsfirma-Solle röntgen, nicht die Schulter.
Ja, Sie hoffen es.
Das war es.
Ja.
Wir machen ja keine Prüfung, Sie sind hier, um zu lernen.
Ja, natürlich.
Oder Ihr aller seid hier zum Lernen.
Ja, ja, ich habe nicht.
Das war es.
Bitte schön.
Nee, also jetzt gehen wir wieder zurück.
Ja, genau.
Und wir wiederholen das jetzt nochmal.
Ab dem Zeitpunkt, mein Verdachtdiagnose ist ein Zerwe Kale Banschein Vorfall.
Zerwe Kale Banschein Vorfall.
Kann man auch sagen, oder Banschein Vorfall im Bereich der Halsfirma-Solle,
HWS kann man auch sagen.
Oder man kann auch Zerwe Kale Banschein, oder das ist mein Verdachtdiagnose.
Punkt.
Jetzt machen Sie weiter, also ob wir nicht gesprochen haben.
Nochmal, okay.
Okay.
Anängen ist ein Unklinik, dort in Erdistan.
Zerwe Kale Banschein Vorfall hin.
Als Differenz der Diagnose kommen
Artrose, Tangenopathie im Betrag.
Ja, zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich gerne
körperliche Unterflugung, Blutabflug nehmen
und Röntgen, Schallanlassen.
Veranlassen.
Röntgen, Schallanlassen.
Frutab.
Schallanlassen.
Schallanlassen, Schallanlassen.
Frutabflug.
Und Halsbereich auch.
Okay.
Ja, das öffnet.
Gut.
Dann, was würde man in, darf ich ein bisschen noch genauer fragen,
oder lieber diesmal noch nicht?
Ja, vielleicht.
Aber ich frage, ist egal, ob die Antwort kommt oder nicht,
ist ja keine Prüfung.
Wenn Sie eine Röntgenaufnahme anfordern,
wie würde diese...
Ja, okay.
Schnee, stehe, stehe.
Ja, ist okay.
Alles gut?
Ja, gut.
Okay.
Wir waren dort zum Beispiel,
dass Sie eine Röntgenanforderung machen möchten.
Wie würde diese Röntgenanforderung heißen?
Würden Sie schreiben für die Halsverbeseite?
Was würde Sie dem Radiologen ein Auftrag geben?
Okay.
Ich bitte um Röntgen.
Halsbereich, wie meinen, ja?
HWS, genau.
Ist egal, wenn Sie auch Schulterröntgen wollen,
wie würde das dann heißen?
Einfach benennen Sie das.
Sie sagen einfach, es ist nicht kompliziert,
sondern einfach die Anforderung heißt,
Röntgen, Schultergelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Ja.
So einfach.
Oder wenn ich Halsverbeseite haben möchte,
Röntgen, HWS oder Halsverbeseite in zwei Ebenen.
Wenn es Fuß ist, Röntgen, Fuß rechts oder links in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, Schulter rechts oder links in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, LWS in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, Hüfte in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen, Handgelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Ich wiederhole das, damit man so lernt,
ist einfach, ich muss nur das Organ sagen, in zwei Ebenen.
Zu acht oder 90 Prozent stimmt das immer.
Nicht immer, aber meistens.
Macht man keinen Fehler.
Deswegen erwähne ich das, dass man das hört.
Ah ja, ist einfach.
Ich veranlasse eine Röntgen, HWS in zwei Ebenen
und eine Röntgen, Schulter in zwei Ebenen.
In der Halsverbeseite wollen Sie was ausschließen?
Was können Sie im Röntgen sehen?
Können Sie das sagen?
Können Sie ein Fraktur?
Zum Beispiel Fraktur, könnte man sehen,
ja, das kann ja keinen Unfallgabe, aber Fraktur kann man sehen, ja.
Was noch?
Die Generative, zum Beispiel,
was wäre eine?
Osterverhose oder?
Wenn die Bandscheinfach weniger wird, zum Beispiel.
Eine Osterchondrose könnte man sehen im Röntgen.
Man würde man Bandscheinvorfall sehen im Röntgen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Man könnte die Bandscheinfach verengen,
das kann man schon sehen.
Man könnte eventuell sehen, ob die kleinen Gelenke
arthrotisch verändert sind,
ob Spondylarthrose, Facettengelenksarthrose wäre,
sozusagen.
Oder die Statik, da ist viel zu viel Säule.
Was würde man im Schultergelenk sehen,
in einem Schultagelenk, Hüftgelenk,
oder in einem Gelenk sehen,
wenn Arthrose wäre, was würden Sie da sehen?
Eine Gelenkskarte?
Ja, Karsifikation, Karsifikation,
oder Karsifikation,
ja, Verkalkung,
zum Beispiel, wenn die Sehne verkalkt ist,
wenn die nächste Kalkaräa, würde man eine Verkalkung der Sehne sehen.
Verkalkung, so sagt man es auch,
in deutschen, also nicht Kalkifikation,
das ist derselbe, glaube ich, aber,
sagt man, Verkalkung der Sehne
oder arthrotische Veränderung des Gelenkes.
Was heißt das?
Gelenkspaltverschmielerung, das ist ein Begriff,
das ist ja auch Gerlopz-Knie, Hüfte, Schulter ist.
Gelenkspaltverschmielerung, schmal,
Verschmielerung, Daralmasse,
verschmal, dann gelühren.
Oder Ostofütere anbauten,
Ostofüten, Knochenanbau,
Ostofütere anbauten,
zum Beispiel,
subchondrale Sklerosierung, das reicht,
mehr braucht man nicht viel zu wissen.
Es gibt auch noch, Grollzüsten und so weiter,
aber ich wollte nur diese auf diese Gelenkspaltverschmielerung.
Beim Kliathrose kann man das sehen.
Deformierung des Gelenkes, kann man auch sagen.
Generell, wenn man eine Schulteraufnahme macht.
Okay, sagen wir mal,
dieser Patient hat keine degenerative
Veränderung an der Halsfürbeseule.
Er hat, sagen wir mal, eine Steilstellung
der Halsfürbeseule.
Das hat jemand in der Gruppe, die sich schrieb,
Düselechmisse, Steilfeelhaltung,
der HWS, als Zeichen eines Schmerzens,
sozusagen.
Wenn jemand Schmerzen hat, hat man auch
Steilstellung der Halsfürbeseule.
Weil die Muskulatur sich verkrampft,
daher kommt es zu einer anatomischen Fehlstellung.
Das kann es dazu kommen.
Die Halsfürbeseule sieht gut aus.
Die Schultergelenke sieht gut aus.
Aber Sie haben ja den Verdacht, der erste Verdacht war,
dass er einen Bahnschein vollkommen hat.
Was würden Sie dann veranlassen, als Untersuchung?
Kraftlosigkeit, derchte ich.
Nein, also Diagnostik, wir sind bei Diagnostik.
Aha, ja, MRT, da gehe ich.
Was wäre der Hauptunterschied zwischen einem Röntgen und einem MRT?
MRT, mit MRT kann man die Weichkeit auflösen.
Oder auf Deutsch weiß ich nicht, aber Jumschattoku,
man kann man Kinder weichteilen.
Weichteile, Weichteile,
besser beurteilen als Röntgen.
Und im Röntgen würde man eher härtere Teile,
oder härtere Gewebe, wie knochen zum Beispiel.
Besser darstellen.
Okay, gut.
Okay, hätten Sie noch Fragen?
Ich habe jetzt viel geredet heute.
Danke schön.
PRP.
Aber Moment, wenn Sie den Verdacht auf Bandsteinfall haben,
dann kann man schon eine Diagnose geben, das ist dann nicht der Verdacht,
sondern wenn jemand, also in der Anamnese,
das haben Sie noch nicht vorgestellt bei mir,
aber in der Gruppe war das einmal ein Gespräch,
Bewegungseinstellung.
Also wenn er HWS-Rotation, Einschränkung hat mit Schmerzen
und Schmerzaustrahlung in linken Arm,
dann kann man denken, dass er ein Schmerz hat,
Ausstrahlung von der Handshöße kommt.
Also würde es heißen Cervico brachialgi,
das ist eine Diagnose.
Also würde bei mir die Diagnose heißen,
meine erste Diagnose,
ich denke an Cervico brachialgi links,
bei Verdacht auf Bandsteinfall, zum Beispiel.
Das ist Verdacht, das wissen wir nicht,
aber dass er Schmerz hat von Nacken bis in die Hand,
das beschreibt er, also es ist meine Diagnose.
Was ich vergessen habe,
an welcher Differenzialdiagnose sollte man auch denken,
nicht orthopädisch?
Ja, Corona-Karriere, Corona.
Genau, also kardiale Beschreibung.
Ja, kardial, infaktional, auch kardial.
Sollte man mit als Differenzialdiagnose mit erwähnen?
Ja, ja, immer auch.
Also um das auszuschließen, haben Sie ja gesagt,
Sie nehmen Labor ab und was macht man noch?
EKG, EKG.
Um das auszuschließen.
Ja, Sie haben das.
Okay.
Hat jemand Frage in der Gruppe?